what comes to your mind when you think
about persuasion some sort of commercial
message urging you to purchase a certain
product or a political candidate
attempting to persuade you to put their
name on the ballot but let us tell you
persuasion is not only limited to these
two things
it's an integral part of our daily lives
many times we believe that we are
impervious to persuasion and we have an
innate capacity to see through a sales
pitch perceive the truth of the
situation and draw our own judgments but
that is not the mere reality according
to psychology certain factors impact our
decision making tremendously
so today in this video we will delve
over the five principles of persuasion
psychology in detail but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply learn
we all live in a fast-paced world due to
which we rely on shortcuts or rules of
thumb more than ever to guide our
decision making
these shortcuts are the common
persuasion psychology traits that
influence one's decision making if you
are wondering what persuasion means let
me tell you that it is the process by
which a person's attitude or behavior
are influenced by communications from
another person
so moving ahead let's discover the
principles of persuasion one by one
the first principle we have is
reciprocity to some extent we humans
value equality and balance
this means we don't enjoy feeling like
we owe other people
for instance if someone gives you a
birthday present you will certainly want
to send them one in return
you'll do this when their birthday rolls
in next to satisfy your feeling of
social obligation
so now you must be thinking about how
this can be applied in a business
environment well think about the last
time that you went to a restaurant
you must have received a small gift from
the waiter about the same time they
brought your bill a small mint perhaps
does that small gift affect the amount
of tip you gave them
you'll probably say no but research
shows that providing a single mint
boosts the tip by three percent
furthermore if the waiter offers another
mint saying that here's one more mint
for you good people then the tip climbs
about 23 percent
this means the amount of tip is
independent of the value of gift and
rather it is dependent on the way it is
presented the key to using this
principle of reciprocation is to be the
first to give and ensure that what you
give is personalized and unexpected
the next principle is scarcity
the less of something there is the more
people tend to want it for example
consider the scenario of iphone 13 pro
devices
due to the ongoing worldwide
semiconductor shortage apple announced
the cut in production of 10 million
iphone 13 pro devices
after this announcement the pre-booking
and sales of this mobile phone went
through the roof increasing time by
about 15 to 20 days
so with this example the science behind
the principle of scarcity is pretty
clear
you will have to create a sense of
scarcity around the product you want to
sell
it is not enough just to highlight the
benefits of your product you will have
to tell people what is so unique about
it and what they might stand to lose if
they fail to consider your proposal
immediately
the third principle on our list is
authority
individuals who are authoritative
knowledgeable and reputed in their
respective fields are more influential
and persuasive than those who are not
part of the justification for this is
that authority and credibility are
fundamental components of trust and we
are more prone to follow someone we
trust
in many realms of life we witness the
principle of authority in action
dentists in white coats are used to
promote toothpaste the camera
capabilities of mobile phones are
marketed with the help of well-known
movie directors
even in the corporate environment
strings of signatures are attached in
the email to improve an individual's
authority
you can achieve this in your business by
recommending others so that they feel a
social obligation to recommend you in
return
the fourth principle of persuasion
psychology is consensus
humans are social by nature and they
typically believe that adhering to the
conventions of a social group is crucial
this belongingness to social proof
always impact human behavior and
decision making
hotel towels are a great illustration of
this persuasion principle
during your stay at the hotel you must
have come across small cards in your
rooms asking you to reuse the towels for
the sake of environmental protection
it turns out this is a very effective
method resulting in nearly 34 compliance
but could there be a more effective way
well the research shows that on adding
the principle of consensus and bending
the words on the message card as 8 out
of 10 guests who stays in this room
choose to reuse their towel can lead to
a 52 increase in the reuse of towels
however this principle of consensus is
challenging to apply from a personal
perspective in the workplace
you'll have to achieve this by
maintaining your brand's reputation and
ethics the last principle we have on our
list is liking
given human nature people are much more
likely to like people that are similar
to them who pay compliments and who
cooperate with them than those who don't
according to cialdini's research a group
of mba students who were asked to get
straight down to business were able to
reach an agreement at a rate of 55
whereas students who were encouraged to
discuss their personal interests before
negotiation were able to reach an
agreement 90 of the time this is simply
due to the sharing of personal interests
and the creation of a sense of
likeliness to consider this in the form
of a business context take the example
of apple stores it's no surprise that
this high-end high-tech apple store is
manned by representatives dressed up in
jeans and t-shirts rather than typical
suits and ties
apple uses the liking principle to its
advantage
this strategy of apple implies i am a
human being just like you i'm casual and
approachable
this strategy creates a sense of
belonging in customers to purchase
apple's products these principles that
we discussed provide for small ethically
sound and often costless changes that
can lead to substantial alterations in
your capacity to convince others to buy
your products
hence conduct a thorough analysis of
these psychological principles and
implement them in your work life that's
all we have for today we wish you all
the very best for your future management
endeavors thank you for watching this
video and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here